American sniper the blockbuster film
about u.s. Navy SEAL Chris Kyle who did
four tours in the Iraq war and became
the deadliest sniper in American history
it's now the highest-grossing war movie
ever and arguably the most controversial
one the New York Times said the film has
fueled a war on the homefront but forget
about everyone else's opinions what do
American vets who actually served in
Iraq think about the film I'm about to
find out my name is Chris Clark I
enlisted in the United States Marine
Corps when I was 18 years old I was an
operator at first Reconnaissance
Battalion I deployed to Iraq twice the
first time in 2005 and then again in
2006 my name is Emily Yates I joined the
army when I was 19 as a public affairs
specialist I did two tours to Iraq from
oh five two oh six and then a seven two
oh eight a lot of the criticism that
this film is generating is that it did
not put the Iraq war in any sort of
context it did not at all touch on the
reasons why America invaded or occupied
Iraq and on top of that it didn't sort
of show any Iraqis or any of their side
of humanize them got a problem in your
eyes no it's not because I think that
what the American public needs right now
in my opinion that is coming from a
veteran perspective I'm a veteran so I'm
biased towards wanting this but if you
want to learn up on the Iraq war there's
plenty of books to read there's plenty
of movies to watch that criticized that
you can you can watch documentary after
documentary about the criticisms and the
mistakes that were made throughout the
war and even the reason to invade itself
the war in Afghanistan in the war in
Iraq or both it's not done winding down
completely and so what we have to deal
with now today is the thousands of men
and women who served in those conflicts
coming home to society that might not
understand what it was like to be in
those conflicts so let me put it to
another veteran then you saw the film as
well what did you think about it
basically what I saw was
vated a country we basically got rid of
all this infrastructure in its military
created so many enemies in doing so and
then you know sent people who really
wanted to do good things for their
country into this this mess
did that make you extra critical of the
film then that it didn't touch on any of
that stuff
why Clint Eastwood felt like he could
not portray any Iraqis as human people
you know as
as people who were actually defending
their own homeland I mean I don't think
that the film leads to these questions
for me like I know that's why that's my
critique of it is that it doesn't lean
right but I don't think somebody should
be why should it because this is Chris
Kyle's story about a man who is a sniper
in Iraq who came back and who struggled
with the transition and it shows that
and I think it does a great job
portraying the struggle that veterans
have when they return which in my
opinion is irrelevant of all the
political questions so I understand how
you're tying it to all the politics and
I've studied Paul I studied politics at
Stanford I understand that the questions
you're raising but the film to me is so
irrelevant of that just like when I was
on the ground in Iraq everything I did
was so irrelevant of politics didn't
matter to me and it didn't matter not a
problem to you that this marine is
saying the politics were irrelevant when
he was on the ground without his
standard I've had two friends in the
last six months killed themselves or
veterans because they couldn't reconcile
what they did what they were being asked
to do and what they did to what they
felt was right and we don't have to call
that political if we don't want to we
can just call it moral and ethical and
because the fact is that killing is not
something that anybody is hardwired to
want to do we do that out of desperation
well I kind of disagree with that
entirely but I mean you go spend some
time in a special operations unit I
think you'll find people who have a
totally different opinion on who you
were trying to kill yeah everyone in the
military you're not trained to turn off
your mind and I mean I was never
was never trained and not think about
politics they never trained but if
you're not thinking about it while
you're in the mission then that's the
training that is actually how many
people who thought about it but it was
so irrelevant of protecting the man to
your left here right but the fact that
and this is another common criticism
about the war that it didn't it it
didn't disconnect 9/11 from the Iraq war
the movie itself movie did not do that
yeah of course but it's stupid but isn't
that a disservice
isn't that a disservice to the viewers
let's play devil's advocate here and to
the American public are gonna watch this
film and are gonna come be like listen
listen if American public's relying on
American sniper to give them the
political background of the Iraq and
Afghanistan wars then I feel sorry for
the American public
one authority on the Iraq war and the
Afghanistan war is American sniper then
okay that's fine you have a very limited
and a very skewed perspective everything
to the American kid out there who
watches this film American sniper and
says I want to join the military like
Chris Kyle and be a sniper I want to
join the Marines like Chris Clark what
do you say to them I want to go to war
basically yeah okay and that's such a
hard question to answer so but it's
happening right so that's why I asked so
I mean
listen people want to join the military
like people have a desire to serve the
country they have a desire to to wear
the uniform and to engage in the in the
the military structure I would say to
any kid who wants to join the military -
to do it with eyes wide open to know
that that it is a political venture
because we're being used as pieces of a
political game